[Music]
biodiversity you've probably heard the
word but what does it mean and why
should we care
biodiversity is the variety of life on
Earth that supports the health of our
planet which helps us in many ways
biodiversity is at the heart of nature
cleaning the water we drink purify the
air we breathe keeping our soils fertile
and providing us with medicine
nature regulates the climate and it does
all this and more for free we need to
look after nature if we want it to look
after us but all around the world
animals plants and the space they need
to live in are disappearing in the EU
42% of mammals 15% of birds and 45% of
butterflies and reptiles are under
threat as landscapes once rich in
biodiversity become ever more scarce
invasive species are upsetting the
balance of nature causing 12 billion
euros damage every year but the good
news is biodiversity loss can be stopped
it's time to invest in protecting and
restoring our life-support systems we
need to leave space for nature for its
sake and for ours find out more online
about the EU efforts to halt
biodiversity loss its network of
protected natural areas Natura 2000 and
how you can get involved
you
[Music]